The One Piece manga just ABSOLUTELY CRUSHED
our souls by revealing the near conclusion
of the epic battle between Monkey D. Garp and
the former admiral Aokiji on Pirate Island.
And I DON’T THINK ANYONE expected the final
result because, in a shocking turn of events,
Garp was stabbed straight through his gut and
then basically defeated by Aokiji and the other
members of Blackbeard’s crew, which could lead
to Garp being captured or even worse killed in
this battle with his former student. We also
got to see even more insane powers from the
Blackbeard crew and a deeper look into the future
possibilities for Aokiji’s role in the story.
But can we please just take a moment to
appreciate just what an absolute monster
Garp is as a fighter. In this chapter, he is
essentially fighting half of an entire Yonko crew,
including an admiral level character in Aokiji,
and he is still dealing massive damage. In fact,
he nearly killed the massive San Juan Wolf by
casually tossing the mountain of a man into the
ocean. Then he blocks a flaming alcohol
blast by grabbing these random pirates,
and then he even has the audacity to
toss the flaming bodies around the town
like they were firecrackers on Independence Day.
What makes this even more impressive is
that he is doing all of this while at the
same time protecting the escaped prisoners and
the other members of Sword while they flee the
island. And by the way, I’m loving the focus
on his raw power during his fights and even
during some of the flashbacks in this chapter.
I personally feel like insane haki and devil
fruits have taken over the series SO MUCH, so
it's nice to see just one man popping off with
his fists. Although he's not technically
doing this alone because Koby, Helmeppo,
Rear-Admiral Grus also remained on the island to
allow the others to escape. Seriously though, I’m
pretty sure Garp would have been better off all on
his own. Because while Koby is tricked into trying
to rescue a random woman, the invisible swordsman
Shiryu appears and is about to stab the marine
Captain. However, we then get to see just how much
Garp cares about Koby because he throws himself in
the way and gets stabbed through the stomach
just like Whitebeard did back in Marineford.
And let me tell you, this moment literally made my
heart skip a beat! Not only because of the shock
factor of the scene itself but also seeing Garp
throw himself around to protect someone else is
such a monumental change compared to his actions
back in Marineford. Because if you remember,
Garp also cared a lot about Ace because
he helped to raise him as a child. Well,
if you consider dropping him off with a
bunch of bandits solid parenting. Anyways,
to put all this into perspective, Garp knew Ace
for TWENTY YEARS. Ace’s father, Gol D. Roger
even trusted Garp to take care of his child. But
none of that was enough to make Garp rescue Ace,
which is why it is so shocking to see him
completely put his life completely on the
line to rescue Koby. I mean, wow, just how
much does he care for this pink haired kid?
We’ll discuss more about that in just a bit,
but first Garp isn’t out of the battle just
yet. In fact, he immediately slams Shiryu’s
head into the ground. And while this deals
some serious damage to the former jailor,
Shiryu gets the last laugh because he knows that
Garp has taken a massive blow. And it’s honestly
pretty lucky for the Blackbeard pirates that
Koby was still on the island because without this
deception that put Koby in danger, I think Garp
probably would have definitely won this fight.
Now, while the battle continues Garp is weakened
but he still has to face the massive threat of
Aokiji and the rest of the Blackbeard pirates.
In fact, at the end of the chapter we even see
Garp bleeding on the ground. Which leaves me
thinking that he might be defeated very soon
OR we could see him unleash his true power.
Either way, Koby is still there to help him,
but I don’t really think Koby can take on all
of the enemies by himself. However, since Garp
already sacrificed himself to save Koby, I could
see him take it one step further and do something
crazy like launching Koby off of the island.
And if this is the case, that would leave Garp
in a very tough situation, which I honestly don’t
think he would escape from. And if that happens it
leaves us with two incredibly interesting options
for what will happen to Luffy’s Grandfather.
The first and most likely option is that
Garp will be captured by the Blackbeard
pirates. But seriously, good luck keeping this
powerhouse hostage. Sea stone won’t work on him,
but maybe Aokiji will freeze him or
something to keep him under control. Anyway,
this option is pretty likely to occur because
in this chapter we even were told that his
Cross Guild bounty is three billion berries.
Which is actually an extremely interesting
number because we also learn that it is
the same amount as a marine admiral AND
you might even remember that it is equal to
Luffy’s current bounty. So I guess this is
Oda’s way of telling us that Luffy is on Garp’s
level now. Or maybe Garp is on Luffy's level?
I’m not too sure but if Garp is captured then
he could actually be used as the bargaining
chip that Blackbeard described back in chapter
1080. Because remember the evil Yonko's whole
plan for capturing Koby in the first place was
to try to ransom him to the world government
in exchange for Pirate Island being recognized
as an official kingdom by the World Government.
And while that ultimately wouldn’t work with Koby
because he is a member of Sword, Garp might be THE
PERFECT marine to hold for ransom. That’s
because he is basically the most famous
marine in the world and he is called the
literal hero of the marines. So if the
World Government didn’t do everything
they could to rescue him it could turn
into a disaster that could cause even more
people to lose faith in their leadership.
But if Blackbeard didn't want to deal with
Garp, an even more absolutely incredible
option is that he could also turn Garp
over to Cross Guild for that juicy bounty,
and it doesn’t take too much speculation to
think that this could lead us to a reverse
Marineford. What I mean by this is that we
could have a situation where instead of the
marines executing a pirate, like they did with
Ace, we instead have the pirates executing a
famous marine. I mean can you just imagine
the chaos something like that would cause
with Buggy broadcasting the show to
the entire world? It would be INSANE.
Though this brings up an even bigger
question. Would Luffy come back to
save Garp? With all the crazy events going
on at Egghead right now, it is hard to say,
but with Ace already dead, it is hard to imagine
that Luffy wouldn't try to save his Grandpa.
And while it's too early to really speculate
any more about that possibility, the other
option for Garp’s future is that he simply dies
during this battle on Pirate Island. And while I
personally don’t see that happening right
now, you can’t say that Garp doesn’t have
A RIDICULOUS number of death flags. Let's count
them, shall we... First of all, he is a likable,
older mentor-type character with no super
clear role in the story, except maybe to
inspire someone. Remind you of anyone. Plus
he is the family of the main protagonist and
we’ve just seen him save one favorite student
while battling ANOTHER former student. And
if that’s not the stereotypical checklist of
Shonen death flags, then I don't know what is.
But if we are taking this option seriously
then we have to consider what would be the
purpose of Garp dying here on Pirate Island.
Is it just to inspire Koby? He did shout out
that Justice would prevail, but as a certain pink
flamingo once told us, Justice is determined by
whoever wins the war. So while inspiring
Koby is certainly possible – although a
little weird since we haven’t seen Garp and
Koby interact a ton in the story – there is
one other option that was hinted at during
all of the flashback scenes in this chapter.
Because in this chapter we see that Garp
developed a deep bond with Aokiji and
the former admiral truly respected his
former teacher. And we’ll discuss more
about their relationship and what it means for
Aokiji’s future in just a moment, but for now,
I wonder if Garp's defeat is actually a
massive misdirection and Oda is trying
to trick us all. Back in chapter 1080 some
members of Blackbeard's crew were suspicious
of the former admiral joining the group, but
killing Garp would definitely show them once
and for all that Aokiji is on their side. So
could Garp really be doing all this to help
Aokiji with some secret mission to infiltrate
Blackbeard’s crew? It is kinda like in Harry
Potter when Professor Snape killed Dumbledore to
gain the bad guy’s trust. Although to be perfectly
honest I don’t know how willing Garp would be to
sacrifice himself since he wasn’t already dying.
But while we don’t know if Garp still trusts
Aokiji this much, he certainly trusts Koby
to be the future of the marines. And I've
always wondered why exactly that is. Is
it as simple as Garp seeing something special
in the way Koby thinks about Justice? I mean,
Koby will do what is right, no matter the
situation. We saw an example of this in
Marineford when he stood up to Akainu and even
recently in chapter 1080 when we saw that he
was perfectly happy to work with this ghost
girl if it meant he could continue his duty.
Or if it isn't just Koby's strong sense of fair
justice, another option is that Garp actually
knows something special about Koby. I mean
we don’t know Koby’s family lineage. We just
met him on this random boat in chapter two, but
maybe Garp does know more about Koby and he has
a clue about some future special power Koby has
inside of him. It's certainly possible considering
all of the new family dynamics surrounding
other characters with interesting hair colors.
Whatever Garp's reason for believing in Koby,
I can’t imagine that the young marine doesn’t
survive this battle, so I’m sure we’ll learn more
about his super important role in the story very
soon. And if you want to make sure to hear all
about the changes Koby will bring to the world,
make sure to subscribe to the channel
for more One Piece content like this.
Now, just like Koby these slimeballs are also
going to play vital roles in the final saga,
and in this chapter we once again see that
the theme of the Blackbeard pirates is to win
using tricks and deception. We saw it in Impel
Down and Marineford, and here again when they
tricked Koby which led to Garp being stabbed.
In fact, we will undoubtedly see some sort of
devious scheme when they face the straw hats. Like
they could kidnap a crew member – I’m looking at
you Ms. Archeologist – or maybe somehow
they get a traitor close to the crew.
Whatever it is, one nearly certain thing
is that Zoro will also have to deal with
Shiryu’s dishonorable fighting style, especially
considering his famous quote back during his
duel with Mihawk, that scars on the back
are a swordsman’s shame. In this chapter,
we also got a better look at the powers of
Vasco Shot. If you remember it was recently
revealed that he ate the Liquor fruit, and we
just now saw him spit out a stream of flammable
alcohol that he somehow set on fire. But what’s
even more impressive were these truly massive
arms that Avalo Pizarro shot out of the island
using his mysterious devil fruit. Seriously,
what is the deal with these powers?
They seem incredibly overpowered
given that everyone in the One Piece
world basically lives on islands.
Though none of that was nearly as impressive
as Aokiji’s mastery of his devil fruit and
especially his overpowered haki that
we got to see in this chapter. And I
don’t care about the power scalers who
will say that Garp was already weak,
but Aokiji’s haki powered fist absolutely
sent Garp flying, so kudos to this ice-cold
dude. And even though Aokiji got thrown
back as well, that’s still incredibly
impressive considering Garp is likely one of
the strongest haki users in the entire world.
That's not to say that Aokiji shouldn't
be thankful to Garp though, because he
would have likely never gotten to this level
with Garp’s training from the past. Because
in this chapter we see in flashbacks that
Garp trained and eventually befriended a
young Kuzan. The former admiral even trained so
hard that he could beat up these old ships on
the same level as Garp. But what’s even more
impressive is that Garp seemed to consider
Aokiji a friend that he could talk to about
his problems. He mentions that his grandson
Luffy wants to become a pirate and that his
SON Dragon started the revolutionary army.
Wait…hold on this is incredibly important.
If Dragon is actually Garp’s son and not
just his son in law, that could mean that…
but I’ll save that discussion for another.
Though one thing that is still really bugging me
is Oda is really trying to make us believe that
Aokiji truly wants to work for Blackbeard. Even
though Aokiji’s justice motto is “Lazy Justice”,
to me he has always seemed like a guy
who wants to do the right thing but
he was still searching for answers. And
to speculate on what he might actually
do in the future, let’s briefly go over
his character arc so far in the story.
It all started in chapter 321. During this fight,
Luffy challenged him to a one on one duel so
that the admiral wouldn’t go after the rest
of the crew. And even though he easily
defeated Luffy, Aokiji didn’t kill the
straw hat captain AND he honored the terms of
the duel by not chasing after the straw hats.
Then we had a boatload of information about the
icy admiral during Robin’s flashback, where Aokiji
was part of the group that destroyed the scholarly
island of Ohara. And Aokiji even appeared to go so
far as to kill his friend Saul after the giants
had betrayed the marines. But then in that very
same chapter, Aokiji seemed to recognize that Saul
desperately wanted to save Robin for some reason,
and he decided to let Robin go instead of
killing her like he was ordered to. To me,
this means that he inherited Saul’s dream that
Robin should live. This idea is further supported
by Robin and Aokiji’s talk outside the banquet
after Enies Lobby. He tells her that maybe she
can answer the question of why Saul wanted her
to live, so really he seems to be searching for
answers that he can’t discover for himself.
Plus we later found out that Aokiji didn’t
actually kill Saul, so there seems to be a lot of
internal conflict for what Aokiji truly believes.
In fact, after the time skip Aokiji left the
marines because he didn’t want to work under the
bloodthirsty Akainu. We next saw him in chapter
698, when he actually saves Vice-Admiral Smoker
from being killed by the Warlord Doflamingo. And
this scene shows us that Aokiji still is a good
person who cares about his friends and the overall
safety of the world. Which makes it even harder
to believe that he is truly evil and joined the
Blackbeard pirates just to take over the world.
But then again, maybe he just really wanted to be
a pirate to have a fun time tossing back the booze
with the boys like we saw in chapter 1080. And
this actually makes me wonder super curious about
what Aokiji's journey would really look like if he
was a pirate from the start. With his powers, he
would absolutely be a massive threat to become a
Yonko and find the One Piece that I went ahead and
thought out exactly how his pirate adventure could
go in this video, which you can watch right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.